I need you to answer my question or I'll
assume you're saying no well I have to
go in the advisement her okay we're
going to carry you to the bed car okay
okay here one arm and one leg okay
okay this is very embarrassing should
walk I know the wife of a former Arizona
Cardinals executive was carded off in
cuffs after an alleged domestic violence
dispute thank you
the incident left exec Bill Bidwell Jr
bloodied and bruised after being struck
dozens of times allegedly by the hands
of his own wife Nicole Bidwell she was
very upset of me authorities responded
to the couple's Paradise Valley Arizona
home on June 9th when police arrived to
the scene they met with Bill Bidwell Jr
whose face has been blurred out and
appeared to be gushing blood so what
happened H she was very unhappy with me
she what she was very unhappy unhappy
with me when I you want to lean my car
I'm going to have the fire department
check you out anyway after police walked
Bidwell over to their squad car so he
can be checked out by EMTs he shared a
detailed account of what transpired I'm
sitting on the couch and she's screaming
at me and I was trying to not escalate
cuz she has a very bad temper and then
she started hitting me and I just
started defending myself she was hitting
you with your hands yeah hard I don't
see my face I don't know if it's Bru or
not I have no idea um she must have hit
me 100 times what were you guys arguing
about she wanted me to come home she
called me she was upset we were having
carpet installed today and she was upset
that I wasn't
here so you got home from work I got
home from work and apparently she texted
me not to come home and I didn't see
that till I was already
home and then when I got in she was
really pissed so she's mad at you cuz
you weren't here for the car yeah then
she was mad that I showed up Bill tells
police's wife struck him over 100 times
during the dispute even at one point
hitting him with a glass she boxed my
ears a bunch of times and you're on the
couch yeah I'm on the couch she's
standing over you yeah okay and then she
picked up the beer that I had just
started I poured it into a glass and she
smashed the beer and landed here
somewhere and shattered everywhere jgs
are probably eaten it okay so she hit
you have with a beer bottle no glass of
beer oh glass poured it into a glass
okay
I'm assuming it was a glass glass though
it was a glass glass and that cut me
here and I don't know what she hit me
with here he tells the officer he tried
to leave but his wife grabbed him and
wouldn't let go admitting to striking
her arms to try to get her off of him
get her off me cuz she's grabbing my
this and she's just beating out of me
unbeknown to me there was a piece of
glass that was attached to my foot so it
was in my shoe so it went Qui and it
took 5 minutes took me to get out of the
closet CU she was trying to trap me in
there beat me
as the officer takes photos of some of
Bill's injuries and wounds Bill nobly
tells the officer he doesn't want his
wife to be arrested offering himself to
be the one to be taken Behind Bars I'm
happy to
go cof she is not going to Officer's
body cam captures his interaction with
Bill's wife Nicole as she's seen laying
on top of a car in the couple's driveway
my dad is coming over all right let's go
ahead and step on down let's get off the
car I just don't feel like it right now
I'm sorry I'm so tired
I'm either you get off the car or I'm
going to make you get off the car what
do you want to do get off theone I'll
get off the the
car I'm sorry it bothered
you I'm so sorry Nicole appears to be
following the officer's orders she gets
off the hood of the car the cop then
asks for her name but when he asked her
to State her birth date she flat out
refuses saying her daughter who is also
a lawyer can speak for her what's your
date of birth Nicole she's going to come
over what's your date of birth I don't
care if your daughter's coming your
daughter doesn't answer for you you're a
grown woman no no no she's going to tell
you she's going to come
over Nicole what's your date of birth I
just told you my daughter's com right
now she's in attorney what happened
today
Nicole what's going on you guys at least
look at me just have a conversation with
me I'm going to let my daughter sleep
for me thank you after a brief stalemate
Nicole eventually lets her guard down
I'm not sure what all
happen he anything to drink
today I'm I'm pretty good thank you and
the reason why I asked because you can
barely have a conversation with me and
you're sl your speech I have very very
that call it's unclear what medication
Nicole took the body cam video redacted
that portion but Nicole told the officer
she was feeling drowsy 2 204 she's
saying she's very sick right now she
took
some so she's not talking to me right
now the body cam then cuts to showing
fire rescue and Nicole's daughter on
scene as Nicole's daughter who says
she's a criminal defense attorney tries
to prevent the officers from speaking
with her mother we're investigating the
crime so she is being detained no crime
i t we're investigating a crime so we
have reasonable I'm defense attorney I'm
representing her you understand that but
we got to investigate what happen but
she can be detained if
reasonable you want to talk to she wants
to talk to me first that's her right
okay well then let her get checked out
by she has blood on her I 100% yeah I
think she okay and then she told me she
took so I wanted her to get it checked
out I that's it stop talking I'm sorry
so let her get her checked out first and
then
have whatever you want to have just
please let us do that and that's it
that's all I'm asking she doesn't you
don't do not want it thank okay I agree
with that
decision yeah our our main priority is
we want to make sure everybody's okay oh
I
understand I'm here out of concern but I
am I am an attorney main concern which
is fine yes thank you I'm just that's
great I'm very very sick today I am very
tired I stop talking but obviously so
you have to look at it from our
standpoint but then things take a turn
when Nicole's daughter appears to assume
officers are jumping to conclusions
obviously we get here your defense
attorney we see blood on
someone he's oh no no no you don't go
there that is a very easy assumption to
make and I see people make attorney no
I'm sorry neighbor no I'm just I'm just
saying that you're an attorney so I'm
just talking about evidence she's my
daughter that we're practicing criminal
defense I'm just I'm just stating that
some apparent Reasonable Suspicion is
what we need to detain someone does want
toally inspected and what else what do
you need to ask
her and I'd also like to say we've been
I've been here for about 60 seconds so
allow us some time talking so we can
detain her for a reasonable time to
conduct an investigation uh not without
Reasonable Suspicion I just stated that
we have reasonable Su that she is we
have to we have to determine what what
crime possible assault BV assault just
um okay I told the neighbors go ahead so
we investigate and then if we find out
that there's not probable cause and no
one's
arrested she doesn't have to let you
investigate if you don't have probable
cause I mean she can't be detained
legally on reasonable suspicions to
believe that there was a crime Comm
committed it the call as a physical you
guys are I mean you know in court this
does not fly you absolutely know it okay
okay the body cam then hudon Nicole
already put into cuffs as she argues
with the officers about being placed
under arrest can you look at me please
Nicole
Nicole this is the last time I'm going
to ask you I just need her to say it's
okay you're talking and not listening
this is the last time that I'm going to
ask you and then we are going to carry
you if you don't want your neighbors and
everyone else to see these two us two
officers carry you to the police
everyone can see right now but you're
going to you're going to lose some
dignity with that and I'd like you to
keep as much dignity as possible right
now I don't want to do that I'm worried
about my dignity okay so are we going to
have to carry you you are going to go to
the police guard either by walking or us
carrying you I suggest you walk that is
your last opportunity what would you
like to do we car walk ask her to come
over you're not answering my question as
Nicole refuses to comply it leaves the
officers no choice but to lift her up by
her arms and legs and carry her to the
police squad car one arm and one leg
okay
this is very
EMB walk I
know now let's go to this side thank
you thank
you once they Place her back on the
ground the officers check her for
weapons before placing her in the back
of the police vehicle despite her
husband not wanting to press charges
Nicole Bidwell was booked on one count
of assault Bill Bidwell Jr previously
served as vice president of the Arizona
Cardinals for several years when his
father owned the team although he
doesn't have a current role with the
football organization the Cardinals
released a statement back in June
stating it was a difficult time for the
family and they were asking for privacy
to deal with the personal situation
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Elizabeth Milner